- Good afternoon, or good
evening I should say.
Thank you for coming to IND 322,
Redefining operations
with Caterpillar's Geospatial
Intelligence Solutions.
I'm Steve Blackwell and I
lead our product engineering
and services team at AWS,
which covers the solution
areas of product engineering
and smart products and services
for automotive and manufacturing.
And today it's a pleasure
having started my career
as an engineer at Caterpillar,
to be co-presenting
with Ash, Alan and Sriram,
who are gonna come up on stage later on
talking about their geospatial
intelligence solution.
So what do we have for today?
So I'm gonna start off
and I just want to give a
brief kind of background
and overview of how we
talk about smart products
and services at AWS
and how we help manufacturers
build their smart products
and services, you know, solutions on AWS
for their connected products
and kind of the capabilities around that.
At that point, I'm then gonna hand over
to the Caterpillar team
who are gonna go through
a little bit of an overview
of, Caterpillar Inc themselves.
And then go into a
little bit of a deep dive
around the Cat Helios,
Caterpillar's digital data platform,
talk about their construction
customer's problems
and how they take advantage
of the capabilities
that Cat Digital have been developing.
Then they're gonna go in
to talk about Cat grade.
And then finally we'll finish off talking
about VisionLink.
Okay, so with that, let's start
and talk about smart
products and services.
So when we work with manufacturers,
smart products and services cover
a broad kind of area
and we break this down into three pillars.
Consumer, commercial and industrial.
You know, consumer is anything
from a robot vacuum cleaner in your home
to a smart plug.
Commercial, anything from
a printer in an office
through to a HVAC system
in an office building.
And then finally industrial,
everything from a Caterpillar mining truck
right through to a
robot on the shop floor.
But across these three areas,
we really see a common pattern
of what manufacturers are wanting
to do with their products.
The first one is be able
to have it connected.
And once that connectivity is there,
it then allows the
manufacturer to then start
providing additional
capabilities on top of that.
The first one's around kind of,
when you see this as a journey,
around data and analytics.
So once that products connected,
they can actually understand
how that product is actually operating
and being used out in the field.
From there we see manufacturers then go,
now they understand how
that product's being used,
they've got a little bit
of kind of data analytics
around use cases like
condition-based monitoring.
They can then start applying AI
and ML on top of that data set
to start providing insights.
You know, a prime example around a product
is around predictive
maintenance for example,
or condition-based monitoring.
But it's not just around the data.
We also say manufacturers looking to see
now that product is actually connected,
it allows them to really focus
on the customer experience
'cause it allows them to understand
how their customers
are using their product
and they can actually start linking,
the telemetry data, the event data,
the usage data of that product
to their customer's insights,
either through their
service management portal
or through their sales team
or their field service teams
that's actually out with the customer.
So they can actually
start developing features
and capabilities and start
improving customer's experience
of using their products.
We're also seeing that
products are evolving as well
and they're now starting
to come a lot more software defined.
Okay, so it's not just around the hardware
and the IoT or connectivity
platform around that,
but really how they can actually start
to provide more features
and capabilities as software
on those actual products themselves.
So that's really enabling manufacturers
to be able to add new capabilities
to those products once they're
actually out in the field,
based on customer feedback
or being able to kind of uplift
and up level that product of
how it's actually being used
as part of new service packs for example.
And then finally we're
seeing manufacturers see,
okay, now I've got my product connected,
now I'm offering all these
different kind of capabilities
around predictive maintenance
or Customer 360, you know,
can I actually change my business model?
Can I go from, you know, selling a product
and offering services,
maintenance support packages
to a product as a service
and generating new kind of revenue streams
or creating new business models.
So that's kind of like the capability,
but we very much see
this as kind of a journey
that manufacturers go through.
You know, a lot of manufacturers
talk about product as a service
but have really gotta start
at the level one that we describe,
that connectivity,
understanding those KPIs,
being able to do provisioning,
you know, device management,
device lifecycle, in
some cases in consumer
or commercial, a product may go
through multiple different owners
or be in multiple different sites
or buildings for example.
So therefore that whole
lifecycle management's
gotta be built into it.
We talked about analytics
and AI and services,
but this is really where
we also see manufacturers
expand beyond their IoT platform
or their connected platform
and start to integrate
it into the aftermarket
parts and servicing.
Okay, so for example, if you know
there's a lot of spare parts,
management as part of
their actual product,
how can you use the
product's telemetry data
to feed into the service team's management
of spare parts,
so unfortunately when
there is a service event,
either proactive or reactive,
and that maintenance
engineer goes out to site,
they actually have the parts
available in their van,
in their truck, to be able
to do the work on that.
And then finally, you know, as I said,
product as a service and
this is really where,
these new business models are coming in.
You know, manufacturers
have been able to offer
SLAs around it
and potentially,
offer capabilities like zero downtime,
outcome-driven engagements.
And as you see as they
go through that journey
of one, two, and three,
we see increased value being added,
to the customer of using those products.
And this is all really
enabled by what we describe
as telemetry driven X.
And that X could be, you
know, parts management,
service management as an example,
but really taking the
telemetry from the product
and actually being able to use it
across the extended value chain
of a manufacturer's business.
Okay.
So what does this look like
from a conceptual
architecture point of view,
from a smart products point of view?
Obviously Caterpillar guys
are gonna come up here
and talk specifically
around their architecture
and go into details around
how they've actually architected it.
But this is really our
conceptual architecture
of how we see manufacturers build out
their smart products
and services platform.
So on the left hand
side, obviously we have
the connective product
and that's gonna need
a secure data ingestion
of the data from the
product into the AWS cloud.
In most cases this is done via IoT
streaming the telemetry,
the events in some cases,
depending on where the product is.
If it's like out in a
potential remote location
where connectivity may be not as reliable
as you would have in a city,
there may be bulk uploads of that data
and that may happen
directly via an S3 bucket
or maybe using kind of APIs based on
the products, determining
what its condition is.
Then within the actual AWS cloud,
obviously that data's
gonna come into a data lake
and on top of that data lake,
which is generally built on Amazon S3,
we start to build those
microservices types capabilities.
You know, fleet management
is like one key capability
we see manufacturers build
as part of smart products.
Having remote control and
remote management is a key one.
Obviously telemetry and event management
is generally where most
manufacturers start.
It's kind of their main use case
to actually drive and
build out this platform.
And then on top of that
they've got analytics
and AI insights.
And then finally,
agents kind of come into this,
especially when you start
to talk about maintenance
and so forth,
identifying an event or
anomaly from the product,
you know, you're gonna bring that
into the telemetry management part.
Obviously the analytics
and AI insights is gonna determine,
is that potentially a part
failure or a service event?
And then obviously those
agents are really gonna come in
to actually orchestrate
creating the service management ticket
for potentially an engineer
or a customer support center
to actually contact the customer
to tell them that actually,
"We'd like to come out
and we'd like to service your
appliance or your vehicle
or your truck or whatever
that product might be."
And then on the right hand side
there's gonna be multiple personas
that are gonna be interacting
with this product platform.
Obviously there's a mobile application,
which the service engineers
or the end users they're gonna be using.
There's probably gonna be
some business intelligence
capability built on top of it
to be able to understand how
the products are performing,
triple usage of those products
from a features
capabilities point of view.
And there's obviously gonna be
enterprise application
integration, the CRM system,
the MRO system for example.
Okay, so I just wanna touch on one thing.
You know, obviously I talked about agents
as part of that platform,
but really starting to
see manufacturers look at,
"Okay, now I've got my
product's connected,
how can I actually bring AI
in to enhance that product
and increase the customer's
experience of that."
And we see a couple of areas
where we're really starting to see AI
really help in products.
First one is around the
product development.
Using AI in a machine-based simulation,
helping those physics-based simulations
or designing the product,
either the hardware, you find
an element analysis or CFD
or in the software development,
where helping the developers test,
validate and integrate
their actual software.
Obviously we see assistance
coming into products
and really helping differentiate
and innovate on that actual product
and how it's being used
and starting to provide more of
a personalized experience,
dynamic UI based on
how potentially that person is using
that actual product itself.
And that's a brief overview
of like how we see smart
products and services,
the types of use cases
and how potentially AI is gonna start
to be used more and more in
smart products and services.
And with that I'll hand over to Ash.
- Thanks Steve.
Good evening.
My name is Ash Shah.
I have responsibilities for
sort of technology strategy
and emerging technology,
engineering technology in our space.
Primarily my team is responsible
for determining the
what we need to deliver
to meet customer needs.
So before we get into
the geospatial solution
that you're all here to hear about,
I want to give a little bit
of a background about Caterpillar,
if I can get this slide to work.
Thank you.
So most of you have
probably seen CAT equipment
as you've been driving on the highway
or have gone past job sites.
What you may not realize
is that Caterpillar
has a global footprint.
We are a multinational company,
we are a global leader in the equipment
that is being built that is necessary
for building the infrastructure
that sort of powers our world.
Our workforce, over 112,000 strong,
exists over in 24 different countries
in 140 different locations.
Combine that with our
extensive dealer network
of 152 dealers operating in 190 countries.
That allows us to bring together
a broad range of
expertise in construction,
mining, engines,
turbines, and locomotives.
We also have millions of machines
operating around the world
on almost every continent.
Of those machines,
1.5 million of those are connected.
So from excavators to generators,
they are all streaming
data to our back office
and we then process that.
So how does Caterpillar,
a company with this kind of breadth,
harness that data,
analyzes it, process it?
Well that is sort of the beginning
of our Cat Helios Data Platform journey
and for that I'm gonna
hand it over to Alan
to go into more details on that.
- Thanks Ash.
(indistinct) again.
Alright, I'm Alan Doty as
they introduced me earlier.
I'm the director of
architecture for CAT Digital.
Digital's obviously a big buzzword.
What we mean at digital at
Caterpillar is our customer
and dealer solutions that enable
them to be very successful.
We're gonna talk about why we built Helios
and we'll talk a little
bit about what we built,
how we built it and then also
'cause talk about the scale
and then I'll hand it
off back to these guys
to talk about one of the
solutions built on top of it.
Why we built it.
By about in 2018 or so,
we had just a potpourri
of technologies that were deployed
across all our digital solutions.
We had Teradata, we had
Cognos, we had Hadoop,
we had Azure, we had everything,
everywhere all at once.
And we heard back from
our customers of dealers,
they were confused 'cause
all these different solutions
gave a different answer
to what my fleet was,
"What's my customer data?"
We didn't really have
very good control of it.
And we had another failed
experiment with outside company
that we usually try to go to
to solve some of our problems.
So our EO got involved and said,
"Okay, we're gonna bring in
somebody that's gonna
help solve this for us
and actually bring in digital talent."
And so I brought in our SVP Ogi Redzick
and he brought in a huge ton of talent
and we set off to build
this Helios platform, right?
We wanted to be confident data,
we wanted all of our
digital solutions to use it,
we wanted to be secure,
we wanted to get all the market
faster on those solutions.
And we also want to improve
our customer experience
most overall, so that way
we can make things easier.
So a little bit of how
we built this, right?
So kind of from a logical
architecture perspective
we're looking at on the left hand side
with point A there we
got all the data we need
to bring in from the different sources,
enterprise sources like what
we built, what we manufactured.
Those things are kind of easy.
But once you got to our
dealer and customer,
that became very complex
because we had a 160 different dealers
are their own businesses,
they use their own systems.
So bringing in their service information
of what they actually did to equipment
was very complex and
try to get through that.
And then as Ash said,
we got 1.5 million connected
assets out out there.
So we had to bring all those assets in
and some of those assets devices
are probably made when I was...
When I graduated college
was a long time ago.
So we brought those in
and then what we had to do was
then bring in all that data
and bring a single point of truth, right?
What is an asset, right?
What is a customer, what is a dealer?
And since all those different pieces
of information came
from different sources,
we had to bring those in.
And then we had to bring in services.
So we didn't wanna just
bring in a data platform
and make a data lake.
We actually wanted to build APIs
and services on top of those
so that way applications can use them
and not replicate the data.
Next we wanted to make sure
that we had data analytics.
We knew the power of the
data wasn't just doing...
Making the data available
but actually putting
insights on top of it.
And we built a large data
analytics, pipelines,
execution and training environment
that we can actually
run and build on scale.
That was always our problem before,
all the vendors couldn't
scale our problem size.
Now we wanna make sure
it's secure to design
and of course we wanna get faster market
and then we want to be able to make sure
we control our costs.
So what did we provide from
a functional perspective?
Like we talked about
from a data perspective,
data was the first thing
we had to get controls of.
We had to get control of
the single truth of customer,
dealer, service, parts,
all those different types.
We have over 325 data objects
that we've created and we mastered.
And those services are then
the drive data on top of those.
So we made sure that those drive services
that we could then build
those APIs, events,
notifications, those sort of things.
We built over 340 of those.
So that way I had one single source API
that would give me what my fleet list is
across all my commerce apps,
my customer app, equipment
apps and all those.
Then analytics, we deployed
over 23,000 models,
high frequency inference
models on-demand, real-time
and some obviously you have
your ML ops training as well.
And then onboarding,
we heard it from our customers,
our dealers the most.
Onboarding a customer is very hard.
It's not like the auto industry
where we've got a VIN number
and you have to go to the state
and get your license, right?
We don't know that.
Someone could just say
that I own this tractor.
So we have to do that a lot more.
It's very hard for us to do.
So we had to do a lot of
investment to get in there,
but we've got 1.7 million
customers on the platform.
So by the numbers we
talk about scale, right?
So obviously we wanna make
sure we're highly available
and that's one of the
reasons why we chose AWS,
over some of the other
cloud providers that we had.
And then we have 296 million
pipelines running per month,
1.4 million API calls
and 50 billion data
records per month as well.
And just an example,
this is all built on AWS
for the most part, right?
And just from an example perspective,
680 S3 buckets, 2.1k
(indistinct) there, 5.7 ECS,
Dynamo and Gateway.
Some of course there's
tons of other services
I didn't list on those.
Those are just the main scale.
And just to show you that it
wasn't just a single database
that we spun up, right?
It's a very complex environment
that you had to move.
'cause our previous people that tried
to solve this before, they're like,
"Oh we'll just spin up
one elastic cache cluster
and one elastic search
will be good to go."
And we're like, "No, that's not gonna work
for the domain size of data that we have."
So we had 15 petabytes of storage,
265 million lines of
code and 3000 pipelines
and one of the happiest things we have
is 125 applications onboarded.
So that's both from a
data BI per perspective,
as well as digital solutions perspective
that are web applications,
things like that.
And that's why I'll
turn it over back to Ash
and Sriram to cover one of the solutions
that they built on top of the platform.
Thanks.
- Thank you.
Alright, so we have
Helios as our foundation.
Now we wanna start thinking about
how do we help our customers solve some
of their toughest challenges.
I'm not gonna read everything
on the slide for you,
but our customers have
a ton of inefficiencies
both in the construction
and in the mining space.
As you can see from the data on the slide,
there is a ton of opportunity
where we can remove
inefficiencies, remove waste.
We want to use the Helios
platform to get the data,
get the analytics to say how do we
take what we have and
help our customers solve
some of these problems.
So before we get into sort
of the geospatial solution,
let's just talk a little
bit about this, right?
Construction customers are
wasting 10% of their materials,
you know, a third of work is redone
and then eventually what that all leads to
is that nearly three quarters
of projects are late.
Any one of you that's
maybe maybe built a house
or gone through that, have
probably felt that pain.
You've seen the inefficiencies
that exist in the construction space.
Now think about that on
a much broader scale.
Some of our big infrastructure
projects, how many
of you have driven down the highway
and you've just seen barrels forever
and you're like, "How long
does it take to update a road?"
And it feels like it's way
longer than it should be, right?
Some of this is a result
of these inefficiencies
where there's just
inefficiencies in the process.
So what we wanted to
do is build a solution
that can try and at least
attack some of these issues.
One of our solutions is Cat Grade.
Cat Grade is Caterpillar's
integrated machine control system
available in a host of different machines,
such as dozers, excavators,
motor graders and pavers.
Think of it like a smart
assistant for heavy equipment.
It helps the operator do cut, fill
and sort of pass with precision.
So it's...
you guys who have modern cars
have like lane assist or auto braking.
You know, it helps the operator
use the equipment better.
This is sort of the same
thing with Cat Grade.
Cat Grade uses GPS sensors
and onboard computers
to continuously track
the position of the blade or the bucket.
It provides near real time
location of the digital design
loaded into the system so you know
how you are operating based
on what you need to do.
So you know if you need to slope it by 3%,
the machine can measure the ground terrain
and be able to tell you
whether you're above or below
and then adjust the blade as it needs to.
So in the cab the operator
gets this sort of feedback,
it allows them to make adjustments
and in fact it'll do
some of that for them.
And then every time the machine
goes over a piece of terrain,
that data is collected
and then sent to the back office
where it can be processed.
Now I explain that a lot.
This video will sort of give
you a quick two minute overview
of Cat Grade in action.
Hopefully this will make
it a little bit clearer.
(upbeat music)
- We're here at Carolina
Cat's demo facility
and today we're gonna talk about the D5
with Cat 3D grade and
VisionLink Productivity,
- We're gonna show you the features
of these technology systems
and how they can help
you do your work faster
and more efficiently.
We have a full 3D plan of this site
and we're using the
machine to get the site
to finish grade in the least
amount of time possible.
- Typically we take a USB
and load that 3D design onto the display,
but with VisionLink Productivity
we can actually remotely
load the design in the cloud
and then download it to our machine.
- We can help reduce the
number of trips to the job site
by remotely managing
designs as the plan changes
and ensure the operators on
the latest and greatest plan.
With VisionLink productivity,
we can remotely access
the machine 3D system
to help the operator with
the most efficient settings
onboard the machine
and ensure that it is on
the correct current design.
(upbeat music)
- With Cat 3D grade
and VisionLink Productivity,
the site manager is able
to manage multiple sites
in a much more proficient manner.
Now that Aaron has the file loaded,
he's actually watching the
display in the light bars
that's giving him cuts and fills
and also horizontal alignment,
no matter where he goes on this project.
We added another feature
called 3D steer assist.
Aaron will select the line
and then the machine will
actually move left or right
so that blade tip stays on the focus line
and gives him not only elevation
but steering guidance to that line.
The benefits of CAT 3D grade,
it allows them to use automatics
once they get close to grade
to be more efficient, more productive
With Cat Factory 3D grade
with VisionLink Productivity,
it will allow you to maximize the return
on your machine investment
and get your projects done quicker
in order to make more money.
(upbeat music)
- All right, hopefully that made, oops,
hopefully that made a
little bit more sense
about what Cat Grade is.
So a lot of that focus was the in machine,
what we call onboard systems, right?
Helping the operator
actually use the equipment.
As was alluded to, and
you may have seen that
in the video,
there was talking about
VisionLink Productivity,
it's now under the VisionLink umbrella,
but what VisionLink will do is
it's the back office web component
that combines with the onboard data
that we're collecting to
really make this solution
viable for our customers
and allows the back office
to help the operator
and make sure that they're working
on the right information.
One of the problems that we have
that we've seen with customers
is that they work on old designs.
Someone made an update,
that update didn't get
to the correct operator,
he or she is now working
and doing the wrong thing.
This system with Visual
Link in the background
allows us to ensure that all the machines
have the latest designs
and are able to do it.
What Cat Grade gives us is the ability
to correctly measure our
metrics, our volumes,
make sure that the right
amount of dirt has been moved.
We can make sure that our
surfaces are properly constructed,
speeding up the job process,
cutting down on waste
and cutting down on cost.
Having the machines at
the optimal blade settings
and just doing the right amount of work
improves our machine performance
and so that the the
ground is optimized for
and the machine is doing
the best job that it can.
And then because of all of that,
because where is less waste,
there is less damage to the environment.
You know, we have an environmental impact
where the construction work
has the minimal footprint
that it can for sustainability.
Now what we've now getting to the heart
of our geospatial solution is we have
all of this data that's
coming off the machine
that now needs to be
processed by our back office.
The solution that we
built on top of Helios
and that is our geospatial solution.
And I'll hand it over to Sriram,
who is our solution architect,
to provide the technical details.
- Thank you, Ash.
Caterpillar is a stronger company,
the stronger our digital solutions kit.
This was Ogi, our chief
digital officer in a podcast,
I'm Sriram, solution
architect with Caterpillar
for the last 10 years.
We look at how Caterpillar,
being a huge manufacturing company,
have been building good digital solutions
for our customers to use.
Let me ask you this,
what is the single important factor
that is needed for a business to succeed?
- [Audience Member] Cost efficiency.
- Right?
Anything else?
(indistinct)
Those are right answers, right?
So, but it's not the revenue,
it's not the market share.
(indistinct)
Yes, but it's not quality as well.
Not even innovation, right?
But it's the customer satisfaction, right?
It that's the most important thing.
At Caterpillar, customer is at the heart
of everything that we build.
So we look at how VisionLink,
that is powered by Helios,
is helping our customers
succeed every day.
Let's do something interesting.
Can I ask all of you to
close your eyes for a moment?
Think of you being in a busy airport,
flights taking off, landing,
moving in every direction.
There is something that
is controlling everything
and keeping everything safe
and coordinated, right?
What is that one thing?
Any guesses?
(indistinct)
I think someone said that...
Yeah, airport control tower, right?
That's the one thing
that is actually keeping everything safe
and coordinated in an airport.
Similarly, in a job site,
be it a construction site
or a mining site,
it's VisionLink that is keeping everything
safe and coordinated,
making sure all our machines
are actually working smooth and same.
VisionLink is Caterpillar's
cloud-based solution
that provides real-time visibility
to what is happening in a job site.
You can track fuel levels,
utilization of every machine.
You can schedule maintenance
from the application,
so on and so forth.
You can actually track where my asset is,
what is it actually doing right now.
All those things are
possible with VisionLink.
With VisionLink it's all
about making the most
out of the data
that you are getting
back to the back office.
We look at...
We understood what does VisionLink, right?
So we look at top three use cases
that our customers are
using in conjunction
with the Incap solution
that Ash was talking.
That we have in our digital solution
that are helping our customers.
We are sitting in this
beautiful auditorium, right?
The surface that we
are sitting on is flat,
but if you look at a job site, a mining
or a construction site,
you are going to have
elevation changes in them.
So what we are doing
is our Incap solutions
actually pick up the
elevation as the machine
is moving on the job site
and that data is transferred
to the back office
and we can have a elevation profile
that can be shown in the application,
so that customers can understand
what is the elevation profile
of the job site that the
machine is working on.
That's one thing.
And our machines actually move the dirt.
They move the dirt from crest to trough
and then move the dirt from
troughs to crest as well.
We call it as cut and fill
and the back of a solution
can calculate the cut and fill volumes.
These two are critical
parameters in our application
where you are able to
understand the lay of the land,
you know how the surface is in a job site
and you are able to
calculate the amount of dirt
that is getting moved
over by our machines.
This is the interesting stuff.
So as you can see, our machines
are sending the data to Helios,
which is actually an upstream
system for our service
that is completely facading everything
that is happening left of us.
So it is just an upstream system,
it's a black box to us
and we are getting the data
from Helios piped into us
and once we get it, we are actually
using a step function.
To parse the data we have
proprietary data formats
that are coming in from the field
and we are parsing the
data using step functions
because we have multiple steps
of parsing that needs to happen.
Once we do that, we store it in Postgres
with a PostGIS extension.
We use that for storing our surface data.
Apart from storing the data,
we use SNS-SQS Fanout pattern as well
to do parallel processing
apart from storing the data.
So we use it for calculating the volumes.
We also do elevation tiles
that we are calculating
and then pushing it to an S3.
While we do that and it
is being obviously served
from CloudFront to the end user,
we are actually invalidating the tiles
as we get surface of the data
from the machines, for example, right?
So you have a one foot by one foot data
that is coming into the back office
and while we calculate if
the elevation has changed,
we would need to invalidate the tile
and make sure that we are
showing the right tile
at the right location.
So the bottom portion is
pretty straightforward.
You have the user talking from the...
Through the APA through
ELB and the Fargate task.
Apart from it, from the browser,
he's able to actually download
the tiles from the CloudFront.
Pretty straightforward stuff.
Now that we know the lay of the land,
we knew that the surface
has elevation changes
and you are able to see
the elevation profile.
The to be state surface,
so for example, typically
you'll have a surface
that is having crests and troughs,
and then there will be a surveyor
who will be surveying
and then finding out how
the two to be state surface
needs to be.
Let's say for example you're
constructing an airport,
you'll need a flat surface
at a specific elevation.
That data is actually
created by the surveyor
and then it is created as a design file
and that will be sent to the back office,
from the back office to the machine.
Before that happens through Helios,
again from the application,
so you can upload the design file
and then you'll be able to
send the file to the machine.
Our machines that are actually
working in the job site.
Before we send this into the job site,
we are able to see the
preview of the file.
So what happens is that, let's say this,
as you would've probably guessed,
I can be a site manager working in Vegas
and probably working remotely.
And then there is a operator
who's actually operating the
machine in let's say Peoria.
While he does that, the file
transfer happens remotely.
And what we had seen is that
these files, as I was saying,
the surveyors use design
tools to actually create them
and we do not have a way
for anyone to have those
softwares to visualize them.
What we have brought in is
a visualization capability
where you can look at a
design file in 3D format
before it is actually
sent to the machines.
So this is a really critical
feature for example, right?
So we had
probably 12 months this feature has been
in the production
and prior to that we had
a lot of customer feedback
where operators were actually
getting wrong design files
because the ecosystem is broken
and we had to actually fill in
and then make sure we are sending the...
Allowing the users to
send the right design file
to the machines.
This one does that.
You'll be able to rotate it
into 3D and then you'll be able to see,
make sure that you have
the right design file
that is actually being sent across.
So this is on the application
and then this one is actually
on the Incap solution that we have.
So you can make sure that
this is the right design file
and then it is actually
sent to the machine
and as I said, sending to the machine
is happening through Helios.
We use Helios to send it
and there were issues that
we worked with AWS team
to have a work around,
circumventing the problems
that IoT Core has.
So these files are huge files
and IoT Core cannot
support these big files.
So we were working around
doing some circumventing
for handling those situations
and then we were able to make sure
these files are actually
transferred to the machines.
This is again a microservice that we have
for processing the 3D preview feature.
So...
Sorry.
So the user uploads a design file
into S3 bucket using a pre-assigned URL
and then it kicks off a SNS-SQS pattern
into a parallel parsing,
where one is we are doing heavy lifting,
processing the design file completely
and then storing the data
into the PostGIS database.
Second one is more of
a lightweight solution
where we are having
the preview generation,
so preview of the file
and the actual processing
are separated out
and one is gonna be heavy lifting.
And then the other one is actually
a lightweight implementation that we have
and it is also served from the CloudFront.
So we generate the file
and it is served from the CloudFront
and then the user is, from the UI,
it is actually pulled onto the CloudFront.
And we do have, as you have seen,
it is having just in time Fargate tasks
that are actually getting
created for processing the files.
Now that we saw that what
is the lay of the land
and then I have the to be state design
and the operator has got
it and he has worked on it.
Once he does that,
what is the proof of
completion of the work?
So in certain geographies,
like Europe and Japan,
you do have mandates from
the government agencies
for some submission of
proof of completion of work,
so that they are getting paid for.
So our customers who are the contractors
would be actually needing this
for generating revenue for their company.
So after they complete the work,
you'll be able to generate
an export of the surface
and it is sent to the agencies.
So we do have multiple plethora of
format of files that we can
generate from the surfaces
and we will be able to
actually allow the users
to download them so
that it can be submitted
as a proof of completion of work.
So this is, as I said,
the surface export completion is probably
going to take a lot of time
because we are gonna
have huge amount of data
that we need to parse from the...
Take from the PostGIS database
and then parse it
and then create the format of file
that the user is requesting.
So that being the case,
this is a synchronous process
that we are kicking off.
The user creates an APA request
and then it kicks off
an asynchronous process
and we generate the file
using a Fargate task again
and then it is actually
stored in a S3 bucket
and we use a Lambda to
actually trigger a email.
So because it is an
asynchronous process though,
the user gives an email and
then creates an APA request
and you are creating the file.
Behind the scenes,
it could take anywhere
between five to 10 minutes
based on the surface that he's selecting.
So for example, a 10 square miles
of quarry are a mining data
that you wanna process
from a surface standpoint
based on how long the
surface has been stored for,
will be able to actually generate the file
and then store it in S3
and the Lambda would be
sending a presigned URL
as part of the email.
So that's kind of how the users
get the email from which
they can actually download the file.
I will, and obviously we are looking at...
We are actually using the bounce
and complaint delivery
tracking capabilities of SES.
We were not having those
and we were actually struggling to capture
how many are actually downloading
and those kind of things.
But now that we have
these capabilities in SES,
we were able to actually take
care of those kind of things.
I will add hand over to Steve
for concluding the session.
Thank you.
- Okay.
So hopefully that was some
good insights into how
Caterpillar and the the Cat Digital team
are building capabilities on top of AWS
for their customers around their products.
And I really appreciate them coming here,
sharing their architectures,
their best practices
and how they've gone through this.
And this is just one example of a customer
that is doing this on AWS.
Other examples are Unox,
who are an Italian manufacturer
of kitchen equipment.
We have Heisenberg, a German manufacturer
that do printing presses.
HP, with their industrial print
presses also have done this.
So we have multiple
examples of how customers
are about building their
connected product platforms on AWS
and not just providing insights
in how those products
have being used for that,
but actually building
services on top of that,
as you saw with Helios and VisionLink
of how they can actually
provide better experiences
and better usage of those
products to those customers.
Okay, with that I wanna say thank you.
I really do appreciate
you staying with us.